Imagine this, you're sitting in a cozy cafe, sipping coffee, scrolling through your phone,
watching this video.
You have high-speed internet, access to unlimited information, and the ability to connect with
people worldwide.
Now, picture someone on the other side of the world, or maybe just in the next town
over, who doesn't have this luxury.
They don't have stable internet, a functioning device, or even the digital literacy to navigate
today's technology-driven world.
Here's the question, in an age where everything is online, education, jobs, healthcare, and
even government services, what happens to those who are left behind?
Stay with me until the end, because I'm about to break down how the digital divide isn't
just about having or not having internet access.
It's about opportunity, power, and how technology is silently shaping a new kind of inequality.
Technology was supposed to be the great equalizer.
The internet promised a world where knowledge was free, opportunities were limitless, and
anyone, regardless of background, could build a better future.
But in reality, the more connected our world becomes, the deeper the gaps grow between
those who have access and those who don't.
The digital divide is about more than just owning a smartphone or a laptop.
It's about who gets to participate in the digital economy and who gets left behind.
At its core, the digital divide exists at three levels.
First, there's access, who has internet and devices, and who doesn't.
Second, there's usability, who knows how to use technology effectively and who struggles
with digital literacy.
Third, there's empowerment, who benefits from technology, and who remains at a disadvantage,
even when access exists.
Let's start with access.
Over 2.6 billion people worldwide don't have internet access.
That's nearly one third of the global population cut off from the modern world.
And even among those who are online, the quality of access varies drastically.
Some people enjoy high-speed fiber optic internet, while others are stuck with slow,
unreliable connections that make even basic online tasks frustrating.
Think about education.
During the COVID-19 pandemic, millions of students shifted to online learning.
But what about the children in rural areas or low-income households who didn't have
a laptop or reliable internet?
They fell behind, not because they lacked intelligence or motivation, but because they
lacked access.
A lost year of education can mean fewer opportunities, lower income potential, and a future defined
by limitations.
Then there's usability, the second layer of the digital divide.
Even when people have internet access, not everyone knows how to use it effectively.
Imagine a farmer in a developing country who has a smartphone but doesn't know how to
access online markets to sell crops at a fair price.
Or an elderly person who struggles to use online banking and gets scammed because they
don't understand digital security.
It's not just about having a device, it's about having the skills to use it in a way
that improves life.
And that brings us to the third, and perhaps the most dangerous, layer of the digital divide,
empowerment.
Even when people have access and skills, the real question is, who benefits from technology?
Big corporations, governments, and tech elites are leveraging digital advancements to expand
their power, while marginalized communities often find themselves on the losing end.
Job markets are shifting toward automation and digital skills.
Those who can adapt thrive, while those who can't are pushed out of the workforce.